AT HOME.
YOU NEED TO BE HONEST ABOUT
THAT.
JOINING ME NOW AS
STEPHEN MILLER, AMERICA FIRST
LEGAL FOUNDER AND FORMER TRUMP
SENIOR ADVISOR AT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND ALSO WITH THE
INDIAN ACT CONGRESSMAN JEN
IS THIS GIVING THE DEMOCRATS
COVER TO STICK IT TO AMERICANS
AND CONTINUE THIS WAR ON PRIVATE
VEHICLE OWNERSHIP AND USE IN THE
UNITED STATES?
>> IT IS VERY CONVENIENT.
THEY SHUT DOWN AMERICA'S
PIPELINE.
CANCELED LEASES FOR OIL AND
NATURAL GAS DRILLING AND PUT
ENORMOUS NEW RESTRICTIONS ON THE
ABILITY TO EXPLORE AND EXPAND
ENERGY DOMESTICALLY AND NOW
THEY'RE SAYING YOU WILL BE
PAYING MORE FOR ENERGY BECAUSE
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
SO IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH ANY
OF THE SITUATIONS WE HAVE MADE
HERE IN AMERICA.
THE TRUTH IS THERE IS ONE
PROBLEM, AMERICA SHOULD TRULY
NEVER HAVE, AND THAT IS PAYING
HIGH PRICES AT THE PUMP OR
PAYING HIGH PRICES TO HEAT OR
COOL YOUR HOME BECAUSE WE ARE
ONE OF THE MOST ENERGY RICH
NATIONS ON PLANET EARTH.
WE HAVE ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
UNDER DONALD TRUMP AND THEY MADE
A DECISION, A VOLUNTARY
DECISION, TO END OUR ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
>> Laura: THINK OF WHERE WE
WOULD BE TODAY VIS-A-VIS RUSSIA
AND THE LEVERAGE THEY WOULD HAVE
OVER US OR NOT IF WE HAD JUST
LEFT TRUMP'S POLICIES IN PLACE.
THIS IS JUST YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF THE SITUATION AROUND US
CRUMBLING BECAUSE BIDEN STAYED
ON THE FANATICISM AND AWAY FROM
COMMON SENSE.
>> YEAH, LAURA,
ACROSS-THE-BOARD, WHETHER YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT GOING OVERNIGHT
FROM AN ENERGY INDEPENDENT
NATION TO ONE THAT IS RELIANT ON
OIL COMING FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES, ESPECIALLY FROM OUR
ADVERSARIES LIKE RUSSIA.
WHETHER YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
BORDER CRISIS OR CRIME RATES
AROUND TO THIS COUNTRY.
ON ALMOST EVERY ISSUE FACING
AMERICA TODAY, THERE'S A DIRECT
LINE BETWEEN DECISIONS THAT
JOE BIDEN AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION MADE IN THE VERY
FIRST PHASE WHEN THEY CAME INTO
OFFICE AND THE CRISIS THAT WE
ARE FACING IN THIS COUNTRY
TODAY.
THE VERY FACT ACROSS THE BOARD
ON AVERAGE AMERICAN SPENDING
$1.25 MORE FOR GASOLINE AT THE
PALMS, THAT IS DIRECTLY RELATED,
AS STEPHEN SAID, TO STOPPING
STOPPING DRILLING ON FEDERAL
LANDS AND ENDING CONSTRUCTION OF
THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE.
THAT IS WHY YOU'RE SPENDING MORE
OF THE POND.
IT IS NOT BECAUSE OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> Laura: STEPHEN, THE NUMBERS
FOR BIDEN IN THE NEW GALLUP POLL
ON RUSSIA, ARE ABYSMAL.
WE KEEP ASKING HOW LOW CAN HE GO
IN POLLS.
IS THERE EVEN A FLOOR FOR HIS
SUPPORT?
I'M NOT SURE THERE IS.
BUT IT KEEPS EDGING LOWER AND
LOWER AND LOWER.
DO YOU THINK THERE IS A HUNGER
FOR MORE MILITARY INVOLVEMENT?
IN THE SITUATION EVER PRECARIOUS
AS IT IS IN UKRAINE?
>> NO.
THE MOST ASSUREDLY IS NOT TO.
I WOULD SAY IF YOU STUDY THE
HISTORY OF WORLD WAR I, WHAT YOU
KNOW IS THAT COMPLEX NETWORKS OF
ALLIANCES COMBINED WITH FOOLISH,
HASTY, OR RASH THINKING CAN
POTENTIALLY LEAD TO ENORMOUS AND
DEADLY CONFLICT.
AND SO WE HAVE TO TREAD WITH
EXPERIENCE CARE AND CAUTION
HERE.
WE ARE TO KEEP IN MIND PART OF
THE REASON WHY PEOPLE ARE SO SAD
JOE BIDEN IS SEEING HIM
STUMBLING AND BUMBLING AROUND
EUROPE TALKING ABOUT UKRAINIAN
SOVEREIGNTY, THEY ARE ALSO
KEENLY AWARE OF THE FACT THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS ACTUALLY LAUNCHED
A FULL-SCALE ASSAULT ON AMERICAN
SOVEREIGNTY THAT HAS ERASED OUR
OWN SOUTHERN BORDER.
SO WE ARE PAYING MORE FOR ENERGY
PRICES BECAUSE OF THIS FAILED
YOUR POLICY, WE ARE PAYING AN
AMERICAN LIVES FOR HIS FAILED
BORDER POLICY.
>> Laura: AND THERE IS AN
INTERESTING COMMENT MADE BY THE
PENTAGON SPOKESMAN ABOUT THIS
BURGEONING ROMANCE BETWEEN
PRESIDENT  --
>> WE HAVE BEEN WATCHING AT
LEAST IN PUBLIC THIS BURGEONING
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN RUSSIA AND
CHINA.
WE WOULD SAY THAT THEY ARE
PASSIVE SUPPORT FOR RUSSIA IS
ALARMING AND RANKLY EVEN MORE
DESTABILIZING TO THE SECURITY
SITUATION IN EUROPE.
>> Laura: MORE DESTABILIZING,
I BELIEVE HE SAYS, THAN EVEN
WHAT RUSSIA IS DOING IN UKRAINE,
CONGRESSMAN.
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR DRIVING
PUTIN INTO XI'S ARMS?
ARE WE STILL SAYING IT IS
DONALD TRUMP'S FAULT?
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT WE HAVE THE
WEEK AS PRESIDENT PERHAPS EVER
IN THE WHITE HOUSE WHO ON A
DAILY BASIS PROJECTS WEAKNESS
AND APPEASEMENT TO OUR
ADVERSARIES.
FOR FOUR YEARS, THE WORLD WAS
FAR MORE SAFE ON DONALD TRUMP'S
WATCH THAN ANY SINGLE DAY THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN AN OFFICE.
THAT IS A FACT.
WITH EVERYTHING WE SEE FROM
RUSSIAN AGGRESSION TO CHINA
CONTINUING TO MOVE TOWARD THEIR
ULTIMATE GOALS.
I RAN ON THE RISE AGAIN ACTING
OUT.
AND FIRING MISSILES AND ROCKETS
AT OUR GREATEST ALLY IN ISRAEL,
ACROSS THE BOARD, THE WORLD IS
FAR MORE SAFER WORKER YEARS
UNDER TRUMP THAN IT HAS EVER
BEEN WITH JOE BIDEN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THAT WEAKNESS THAT PUTIN IS
SEEING, THAT IS WHY HE IS ACTING
OUT THIS MOMENT.
I'M TELLING YOU, CHAIRMAN XI AND
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY ARE
WATCHING THE BIDEN WEAKNESS AS
WELL JUST GOING TO HAVE EVEN
MORE DISASTERS CONQUERED,
CONSEQUENCES DOWN THE ROAD.
>> Laura: WHY DO THE ELITES
THINK THAT AMERICANS CARE MORE
ABOUT DEFENDING UKRAINE'S BORDER
THAN OUR SOUTHERN BORDER?
I NEVER DID FIGURE THAT OUT.
>> I THINK FOR SOME OF THEM
THERE'S A LOT OF FINANCIAL
INTEREST INVOLVED AND WE HAVE
SEEN THAT WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
FAMILY.
IN OTHER CASES, THERE'S ALWAYS
BEEN AMONGST BOTH NEO-CON AND
DEMOCRATS -- WILL BEING
COMPLETELY AND EMOTIONALLY
DISCONNECTED FROM AND HAVING NO
EMOTIONAL ATTACHMENT TO THEIR
OWN CITIZENS, THEIR OWN COUNTRY,
THEIR OWN BORDERS, AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION TYPIFIES THAT,
PERSONIFIES IT AS NO
ADMINISTRATION EVER HAS BEFORE.
THEY TRULY DO NOT CARE ABOUT THE
FACT THAT YOU HAVE CHINESE
FENTANYL POURING THROUGH MEXICO
INTO OUR COMMUNITY, MURDERING
OUR CITIZENS, -- N